je vais d'abord on revient sur la 10e
journée de mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites les manifestants
avaient une nouvelle fois rendez-vous
dans le centre ville de Tours ce mardi
matin la semaine dernière ils étaient
entre 10 et 12000 dans le cortège avec
la participation active des étudiants
l'université d'ethanneurs est d'ailleurs
toujours bloquée alors le ralliement de
la jeunesse pourra-t-il faire plier le
gouvernement Faustine Luneau est allé
interroger les jeunes présents dans le
cortège
[Musique]
la jeunesse dans la rue c'est encore le
cas ce mardi pour la dixième journée de
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites à Tours 5700 manifestants
selon la police 9000 selon les syndicats
au sein du cortège encore beaucoup
d'étudiants qui se sentent eux aussi
touchés par cette réforme nos parents
ils sont quand même concernés donc
forcément ça nous concerne aussi nos
familles et même en solidarité même avec
les travailleurs etc on sait que ça peut
être compliqué et on sait ce que ça
implique et aussi on se dit que on peut
être concerné plus tard parce que si
c'est au départ décalé à 64 ça va
décaler ensuite et c'est que le début on
va dire qu'on a notre mois à jouer
surtout nous les jeunes en plus je
trouve que c'est hyper important parce
qu'on parle quand même aussi de notre
avenir ça nous concerne peut-être pas
maintenant mais ça va nous concerner
dans tous les cas dans un futur assez
proche en plus des jeunes qui se sentent
concernés mais pas écoutées au-delà de
la réforme des retraites c'est un
ras-le-bol général qu'ils expriment
[Musique]
quand j'ai entendu parler de ça et que
on a parlé du 49-3 pour l'enihème fois
je me suis je me suis mise devant public
Sénat j'ai regardé et j'ai juste entendu
les députés parler de problème qui sont
tellement pas des problèmes pour nous
qui nous concerne absolument pas on
parle de rembourser la dette de l'État
nous on a absolument rien à voir avec ça
les syndicats étudiants se sont joints
au mouvement dès les premières
manifestations mais c'est depuis
l'adoption de la réforme le 20 mars
dernier que les jeunes se font
particulièrement entendre dans les
cortèges à l'heure où on utilise le 49-3
parce que le peuple dit non
là c'est un combat ou aussi on lutte
pour la démocratie en fait on lutte pour
nos droits en général on lutte pour
notre droit à la parole c'est aussi pour
ça qu'on est dans la rue ce mardi la
manifestation s'est terminée calmement
aucun débordement n'a été signalé y
compris à Blois ou moins de 5000
personnes étaient dans les rues